finally new rule if you want to
understand why America is so divided
don't talk about Republicans and
Democrats or red states and blue states
read the story the city mouse and the
country mouse currently being sold under
the new titled
what happened but the original was about
two mice who learn that you're either
one of the other city or country and the
same really could be said for America
when you fly over it you don't see red
states and blue states you see vast
stretches of land where there's nothing
and then every once in a while a city
hears Missouri but every state looks the
same a sea of red with a few blue dots
know I could joke about Alabama all I
want and believe me I want its trump
country but not Birmingham because
that's a city it voted for Hillary
something happens to you when you live
in a city you get mugged but you also
have a multicultural experience cities
are places with diversity and theatres
and museums and other gay stuff
I have nothing against rural life but
I've seen farms on TV and they look
dusty Republicans are freaking out
lately because it seems Trump is
pivoting from these two to these two
colluding with Russia fine but Democrats
but really it's not that complicated
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi their
city mice and that's who a consummate
New Yorker like Donald Trump relates to
why is he always poop tweeting at 3:00
a.m. because he's from the city that
never sleeps he's such a New York guy he
had his last wife delivered
Trump's disillusion with mcconnell and
ryan it's not really political it's just
that for the first seventy years of his
life he would never be caught dead
hanging around with a traveling bible
salesman like paul ryan or a corny
countrified goober like Mitch McConnell
for Christ's sakes the man is from
Kentucky Jeff Sessions is from Alabama
when he when he what he talks all Trump
ears is a tiny little Ernest movie and
Mike Pence it must be torture for Trump
to be in the White House every day with
that homespun Christian tightly wound
human hard-on he he literally won't dine
with an unchaperoned woman meanwhile
Trump has spent his entire life posing
with a shit-eating grin that says look
at all the [ __ ] I'm Gary
[Applause]
and this is the existential crisis of
our president he's an [ __ ]
but he's not a hick he represents one
group but belongs to another I hate to
break it to you real Americans but what
Trump likes about Chuck and Nancy is
they're not you he's not one of you
trust me when Trump watches The Beverly
Hillbillies
he roots for mr. Drysdale and when he
tells a crowd as he often does I love
you what he means is that in middle
America he found something he had long
ago run out of in New York suckers Trump
voters
Trump voters were played for rubes by
the ultimate fast-talking city slicker
who saw vulnerable people nervous about
jobs and the melting pot getting too
melty and he told them he build a great
wall and get their jobs back at the mine
and they said where do I sign
folks you didn't make America great
again you enrolled in Trump University